Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
there's this guy Eric from Mass. Who has been
calling in with all sorts of COVID conspiracy
theories since the start of the pandemic. I
told you last week that Donald Trump has been
asking around about ways that he might be
able to imprison journalists adversarial to
him if he were to become the president of the
United States again. And I think imprisoning
journalists for their opinions is bad. Eric
from Mass says, I should be imprisoned for the
things I said about COVID. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David from Mass. I just
watched the thing I put about Trump and the
journalist. Looks like you might be embarrassed
after all the lies and stuff with COVID and all
the people who got hurt with vaccines, you know,
they will live, but they don't want accountability
for it. Lying and people scaring people.
Speaker 1: You know, Eric still seems to struggle
with the understanding that I don't create any
views or make assertions myself about vaccines
or COVID. I. I'm a commentator. I bring to you.
The best synthesis that I've done of the
medical science. And Eric continues to
talk to me as if I'm coming up with the
information about how vaccines work or
anything about COVID. It's very strange all.
Speaker 2: Over a common cold. Make people wear
masks and the kids wear masks. Disgusting.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I didn't do
anything. I didn't make anyone do anything.
Speaker 2: Absolutely disgusting. What you did
notice. And you must be in your pants thinking
that accountability is coming. And that's one
thing you Democrats. You never. However, from
pregnancy to anything else. Take accountability
for your own actions. But you did it. You've
had people killed. You have people hurt. Hey.
Speaker 1: By the way. Democrats don't take
accountability for pregnancy. Have you heard
of Herschel Walker? So, Erik from mass. Still
struggling with thinking and common sense.
I predicts I will not be imprisoned for my
reporting on vaccines. Maybe there's a place
that will take your bet on that. I would not
bet on me being imprisoned for COVID coverage.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We are going to go through all of the
scenarios in the House of Representatives that
could lead to Republican control or that could
lead to Democratic control. Not a conversation
I expected to be having with you today. That's for
sure. We're also going to talk about new polling
which went to student loan borrowers and said if
you had student loan forgiveness or for those who
are getting it, what do you plan to use the money
for? And the answers were very interesting. And a
lot of people misunderstand the answers. A lot
of people I don't know if deliberately or not.
Seem to be thinking, oh, see, their answers
to what they're going to spend the money on
proves it wasn't a good idea to do the
forgiveness. Very much the opposite. We
will talk about that. And number three.
Dave Chappelle hosted Saturday Night Live
over the weekend. And one of the things he did
during his monologue was he criticized Kanye
West. He criticized Kyrie Irving for their
anti-Semitic statements. But in so doing,
Dave Chappelle reinforced some of those very same
anti-Semitic tropes. Very disappointing to see
the right loved it. The right now they see Dave
Chappelle as their hero, but it was pretty bad.
So we're going to talk about that on today's bonus
show as well. Sign up at join Pacman dot com. Join
Pacman dot com. You can use the coupon code. 24
starts now. I believe 24 starts tomorrow with
Donald Trump's announcement, although now there
are rumors it might only be remarks, it might
not be an announcement. Well, we will figure it
out very quickly. Join Pacman dot com. Coupon
code 24 starts now. We will see you on the
bonus show or otherwise back here tomorrow.